also erstmal bin ich halt schwer
pflegebedürftig und hochrisiko fall
aufgrund meiner neuromuskulären
erkrankung school distribution
das ist ein fortschreitender
muskelschwund nämlich größtenteils
bewegungsunfähig gemacht und sich halt
auch auf herz und lunge auswirkt das
heißt ich habe nur noch ein volumen von
etwa 20 prozent und werde bereits den
schon am tag beatmet also mediziner
haben bereits im märz vor meiner
erkrankung gesagt wir sollen uns
isolieren und kontakt vermeiden
gut es eben geht eben weil schon normale
erkältung wie jemanden wie mich der
gefährlichen und schnell zu
lungenentzündung führen können also ist
bei mir schon von einem hohe
sterberisiko auszugehen
die besonderheit ist jetzt aber ich bin
also wirklich sehr schwer isoliert aber
das ist leider auch nur sehr begrenzt
möglich weil ich nämlich den
höchstmöglichen grad habe und ich lebe
heute einen selbstbestimmten pflegen
modellvielfalt schon das ist es genannt
das heißt ich beschäftige selbst ein
team aus neun teils gelernten als
ungelernte kräfte die nicht pflege
unterstützen ich bin halt auch immer auf
sie angewiesen und dadurch trotzdem
einen erhöhten risiko einer infektion
ausgesetzt bevor walter zu sagen also
sterberisiko und infektionsrisiko die
zwei großen kriterien die von der stiko
auch für die info ordnung genutzt wurde
sind also hier hinlänglich gegeben und
dennoch tauchen kälte wie ich gar nicht
in der impfung auf